[Música]
algunos sueñan con el premio toda la
vida que logró obtenerlo con tan sólo 39
años emanuel macrón desde lejos del
presidente más joven de la quinta
república un hombre apresurado amante
del piano y de la filosofía economista
egresado de la escuela nacional de
administración el nativo de la ciudad de
ame a se hizo notar en su paso por el
banco rothschild
y luego descubrir el elíseo como
secretario general adjunto con tan sólo
34 años ya se ubicaba en la élite de
quienes le hablaban al oído el
presidente dos años más tarde este
ambicioso treintañeros se convirtió en
el ministro de economía un ascenso
fulgurante que generó curiosidades donde
quiera que iba lo esperaba en los
micrófonos que manuel macrón presentó
sus ambiciones
eliminar los rojos que hay de manera
concreta nuestra economía son sus
iniciales así como las de su movimiento
político en marcha creado en 2016
como distancia del socialista françois
hollande
yo soy de izquierda es mi historia pero
hoy la izquierda no me satisface uno de
los pilares de la izquierda son las 35
horas de trabajo por semana una trampa
para él manuel macrón quien prefiere ver
a los franceses en el trabajo la mejor
manera de pagarse un traje es trabajando
macro sacudió el paisaje político
francés las presidenciales de 2017
pasaron a la historia por primera vez en
la quinta república ni la izquierda ni
la derecha llegaron a la segunda vuelta
pero europeo de mayor makro vence a
marín le pen con menos de 40 años
comenzó un tumultuoso mandato de cinco
años
chalecos amarillos acaso ven a la la
movilización contra la reforma de
pensiones
pandemia de kobe 19 las dificultades se
multiplicaron así como las críticas el
presidente contraatacó
nos hemos convertido en una nación de 66
millones de fiscales y así no es como
solucionamos los problemas sus últimos
dos años estuvieron marcados por la
crisis sanitaria para salir adelante
macrón apostó por una vacunación masiva
aunque eso signifique según sus propias
palabras fastidiar a los antivacunas no
solamente ponen en peligro las vidas de
otros sino que también restringen las
libertades de otros y eso yo no puedo
aceptarlo macrón ahora ha logrado algo
que sus dos predecesores no pudieron un
segundo mandato en el cargo